j'aurai besoin de ta cravate tu veux
quoi sinon ta cravate enlève là non pas
de question que j'enlève man ray park à
berriac annonce un jeu famélique tard au
calme toi je suis bien prêt c'est moi je
suis comme chez toi en plus ça me écoute
écoute moi que ça suffit de stop tht
intérêts m'expliquer ce qui se passe à
trois comptes ok ok tu sais quoi j'ai
mis la charrue avant les boeufs pour
faire court est ce que tu marches ou pas
qu'est ce que je marche pas dans quoi
c'est pas le moment pour les questions
on est dans l'action tu marches ou tu
marches pas ok mais dans ce cas là je
marche pas non ça c'est bête ça dis toi
que tu marches déjà quoi merde pourquoi
tu me demandes parce que je m'attendais
à un truc du genre je marche bob et tous
les deux on se serait éclaté comme des
malades mais toi tu as tout cacher et
c'est dommage j'ai tout cas ok ok ok
écoute écoute m'empêchait te parle toi
mon gars je sais pas dans quelles portes
s'étaient fourrés mais je suis sûr d'un
truc c'est que je suis ultra ultra pas
partant pour marcher et je marche pas du
tout